[Music]
yeah i love garage saling so much
and like finding a teddy bear for 30
cents that i know is six bucks on ebay
that high is the same high i get doing a
50 million dollar
ipo on an nft project they're not
any different i'm just in the cocoon of
my process
[Music]
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
gary what's up good to see you what's up
it's good it's good to see you too bro
yeah uh so the podcast um
is all about well-being and kind of
how successful people take care of
themselves
their journeys and how they take care of
themselves and i really want to dive
that
dive into that with you because you're
always seemingly running at
a thousand miles an hour like how do you
look after yourself your mind your body
when you're doing everything that you're
doing
i think this is a great question i think
first of all thank you for having me on
and second of all i'm really enjoying
watching you go through your process
here
because i think you have a lot to add to
a lot of people and i know a lot of
people look up to you and so
i'm really enjoying it and i know i've
been pinging you occasionally telling
you that and so
that's why i'm so happy to be on the
podcast i appreciate you doing it
thank you actually it's really
interesting actually i think i have a
little bit of i actually know this is
gonna
be a breakthrough for some people i i
think most people
are in tactics on this one
not not you know religion
so what i mean by that is
um the reason i
am in such a i would call it fairly
anxious free
especially when you consider what i'm up
to
very happy state is because
i fixed this the well not the sink
i'm in religion not tactics here's what
i mean by that
it is more fun to me
to run a business and start a business
than it is to go golfing
or water sports at a lake or
tennis or the movies
it's why so many people that work with
me are my friends
my actual happiest place
is in business creation and operations
so i really found your joy yeah this is
why i was so unhappy
in my youth at least from my school day
to day
i was so quickly called third grade
fourth grade latest in this weird kind
of like wisdom you know i spent a lot of
time with
grandparents and old people not my
grandparents because unfortunately they
died in the old country in russia but
would always be attracted to old people
would sit with them on the bus and talk
to them with
at the park and i don't know if i'm an
old soul
where i extracted a lot of wisdom but by
fourth grade i'm like oh this is not for
me
that's okay that's not like i'm a
spoiled brat
and i don't want to do school it's oh
this is really not for me
i really love this thing business
selling baseball cards lemonade stands
like in the summer it was more fun to me
while my friends were like hey let's go
do slip and slide or play baseball i was
like yes
and i like those things but one out of
every two days in the summer
i was like let's go wash cars let's do a
lemonade stand
let's start a flea market it was just
very natural for me
to want to do business and so
when peop this is why i'm always
interested in doing longer form content
because i want people to hear this
i don't burn out
because i'm not about the money i'm not
buying homes that i can't afford
and i need them people burn out when
they're anxious
or stuck i don't need the money to buy
something to impress people
i don't need the money to pay my bills
why
because i lived far more humbly than my
earnings and i did that by the way
justin not today when i make a lot more
money when i was
in my early 20s building my dad's liquor
store for him
i was making 40 50 000 a year but i
lived in a [ __ ]
1400 apartment and then basically did
nothing else
like literally have no other expense
when you don't go out when you don't buy
stuff when you don't
need 800 sneakers when you don't need to
go to coachella
so and by the way there's nothing wrong
with all that stuff and i want everybody
to enjoy their lives but i was so
self-aware
that and and so the answer to your
question is
i'm doing what i love every day truly
not some [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] like love what you do
you like you know that
that you know that you know love what
you do never work a day of your life
there is no bigger poster child for that
than me i
genuinely like what i do every day more
than every alternative besides
the thought of like spending time with
my family who's not in my business
like like you know like i love
that about that's why i have a business
with my dad and my brother
right and like yeah why i why i even
have thoughts of like can i do something
with my sister it
forces me to spend more time with them
because this is my playground that i
want to be in
i love going out to dinner with them
after work i love the weekends we have
i love vacation i love all that i love
family time
but i don't think people burn out
because they don't have enough family
time i think they burn
out because they have this very poor
relationship
with the money they're trying to extract
out of their career or business
and how they spend their money in their
life and what they spend
their money on yeah i totally
that really resonates with me because i
think i you know i
i was in that place for most of my
career where i was
trying to do something dude do
everything for external reasons right
extrinsic reasons to make money
to be successful to be somebody and that
was a huge
struggle for me and i was doing things
that i think a lot of people on the
outside would probably say like oh he's
probably having a great time
but i wasn't you know having you know
wasn't intrinsically motivated and so it
was like
such a struggle for me what's funny
about it is
it was a struggle from your like the way
you put your head on your pillow at
night
but it was a driver to some successes
you've had and i've been fascinated by
this
uh you know something i started saying
five or seven years ago
uh how you make your money is more
important than how much you make
and what i noticed was oh [ __ ]
the people that achieve either look like
me
or the bizarro reverse version of me i'm
so internal and i'm justin
it is so crazy how out there i am
i i guess actually this will make sense
one of the i think if you're going to be
really out there like you and i have
been in our you've been in the past and
i
i think it's one of two extremes
it's you are really out there for
external validation and that's
that's oxygen but i don't think that's
sustainable because it's an
unhealthy relationship with the world
because they can tear you down
or mine you're in such a cocoon that you
fear
nothing from the outside so you can put
yourself out there
because when they say you suck or they
don't think you're successful you
actually can't hear it which
is cool because when they tell you when
you're on the other side of it which is
i'm starting to swim in that lake you're
the best i mean people say crazy things
to me
like incredibly i'm incredibly overrated
in a small group of people's minds
and i'm incredibly underrated i think in
the masses
and like and and what's cool about that
is when you're in a cocoon and can't
hear it
and you're just about you and your
process the booing
doesn't hurt and the cheering doesn't
feel good either
and by that you're just in silence of
your own [ __ ]
it's like for example the way i feel
being garyvee or building big businesses
or being successful
is really no different than the way i
feel like when i'm garage sailing on a
saturday
like i love garage sales so much and
like finding
a teddy bear for 30 cents that i know is
six bucks on ebay
that high is the same high i get doing a
50 million dollar ipo
on an nft project they're not any
different
i'm just in the cocoon of my process
that's so powerful how did you so how
did you
get in that cocoon or like discover that
for yourself
i think that's probably the biggest
driver between peace on
the back of garyvee i think i am driven
the reason i think i became so public
in hindsight is two reasons one i
knew that what was gonna happen with
social and like the internet
i feel like you did too and like you can
go back to those two thousand six seven
five days like
there was a group of people that
inherently understood
yeah i had this insight that it was like
people want to follow people
right that was the kind of impetus
between behind justin tv
and you really took it and ran with it
oh i remember thinking oh [ __ ] this kid
i have goosebumps i don't know if you
can see him i remember exactly what i
thought the first day i saw it i'm like
oh [ __ ] you know i was already friends
with justine right by justine and all
that i was like
so the justin thing god i just remember
exactly how i feel that so i just
brought up i just seen big shout out to
her
i was like oh this dude
is gonna live a very literal version
of what i know i'm about to do in a very
different version because you probably
know this as well
a little bit of the differences i keep
my private life very i kind of but
but it was still the same thing to me
and i remember thinking how brilliant it
was
and and and then like as a platform and
obviously
you had all the evolutions of it to your
success
i the the answer is i think i became
gary vee
in a lot of ways because i was felt
gratitude and guilt
both yeah they were they were almost
even
the answer to your question is
impeccable
parenting ridiculously fortunate
circumstance
being born in the soviet union coming to
america
having nothing being in the 80s in new
jersey which meant you spent 10 hours a
day outside
luck of the draw on dna then i had you
know not only was i given the
ingredients
with my chemicals but then my mother was
the best chef of all time with emotional
intelligence and accountability
so like how do you build ridiculous
self-esteem
while not creating entitlement and
delusion is [ __ ] hard
yeah and my mom and my mom did it for me
she cooked
that meal so i almost feel like and it
took me a while
probably last three four years even on
this one i was like oh [ __ ]
this is just homage to my mom i want to
do for the world
what my mom did for me my mom did this
for me
people really gravitate towards my words
i have a communication style that really
is unique
i can do this for the world and and this
is awesome
like like being admired is so much more
interesting
than being uh known like
like when i look at somebody looking at
an athlete or a social media influencer
or a model or an actor
and i see how they react to them versus
how i see how people react to me
i want everybody to live my life for
them it feels incredible to be
to be to be asked for a selfie out of
the admiration that you gave them
something
that really has helped them versus
they wish they were like you or think
you're hot or like it's cool
it has been really incredibly rewarding
you know it's nice to be admired it's an
intoxicating feeling
and the only way you could be admired is
not put on a pedestal for an
accomplishment is
you're impacting them not they like what
you've done
it's a different level it's a different
version of admiration
so anyway how did i get there by being
incredibly
fortunate that i had chemicals and
parenting
and circumstances that put me there and
then had the
dna to become aware of it very early on
and then hone it i i became
in high school i realized why is peer
pressure not penetrating me
it's very weird just to tell you the 14
15 16 year old me
would have conversations with him of
like why is this really not working on
me
like why am i willing not to compromise
on things for popularity why am i
willing not to be mean
if i'm willing to be a little bit meaner
and pick on kids i could go to that next
level
and be at the height of popularity in
high school because i was right there
because of my personality
wouldn't compromise it and that's what
was needed for high school in the 90s
you need to you need to go that next
tier you had to compromise a little bit
on kindness
it wasn't cool like it is now to be
sweet and warm to everybody
but i had to be that because that's who
i was and that's how i was parented
or later even in like college like
why won't i do these drugs because i
know that will get me this girl
right now like you would have these
conversations with yourself of why you
wouldn't compromise to peer pressure or
outside
validations that's a really high level
of self-awareness
for a young person to be able to have
that that
internal conversation where you have
that magnetic cognitive like analysis of
why you are a certain way
and then yes and it's like cool to
figure out that
in my 40s i'm like [ __ ] i have that cool
how do i talk about
and then in parallel to that
self-awareness
have a level of humility to not think
you're special because of it
so the thing i'm fascinated by is
how do you how powerful to
anxiety starting back to where we are
how much humility and accountability
make me happy on a daily basis
how do you communicate that to other
people or how do you teach other people
because you like you said you had all
these ingredients you know like and then
your mom was this amazing chef
and then a lot of people following you
you know they might have not have
started in that place
right they might not have um but they're
by seeing i see
you know where my confidence came from
my father my dad was on the opposite
side
and i was his son coming into a business
and i spent a decade plus
my dad now what i learned from that is
just like i know that
in many areas that don't come natural to
me for example if you're like if you ask
me right now in the podcast gary can you
become a better singer
i'd be like of course i could become a
dramatically better
better singer i can take it seriously
mentally i can hire a voice coach
because i can afford it
i can practice every day and in three
years
i could become a much better singer can
i become
beyonce no and
what happened was justin watching my
father
and then subsequently the last 20 years
25 years
watching people that are very close to
me
evolved and then watching my own self
evolve in an area where i really
struggled which was believe it or not
stick with me or candor
i'm incredibly candace as garyvee in my
content i was incredibly
visceral to conflict which made me
incredibly not candarous as gary
vaynerchuk the executive
which created macro entitlement in my
organizations
and created vulnerabilities with my
direct reports
that i wanted to be different about in
my 40s and have gone through this
incredible journey
on standing up what i call kind candor
which has been a missing ingredient in
my career and in the last two years i
think a lot of things have exploded for
me in a positive way professionally
on the back of me starting to evolve on
something that doesn't come natural to
me
my mom doesn't have it either so she
didn't instill it
and thus it was a vulnerability and i
can't believe how much further down the
path i am
same with my physical health you know 38
and a half years of garbage
around muscle gain and but least
natural thing i have a workout later
today i'm like dreading it
every day i've worked out every day for
six years and still
dread it but fought through it and what
yeah what that did was give me the
confidence that the kid
or the grown up on the other side of
that tick tock or that facebook post or
this podcast
and it said why i think i give a good
interview people are like man you give a
really good interview i'm like it's
because i'm desperate
right now that there's one person
listening to this
and i know what kind of inspiration you
are to so many
so i'm imagining who's listening and i
know my name is this week's guest so i'm
imagining who's
listening and what i'm trying to do here
in our 45 minutes is can i get
one person to self-reflect
to become a little more self-aware to
feel a little less scared
to tell themselves the truth
and then like move them right
and so yeah and to me it actually comes
from the following there's been a
thing that i've been saying that's
really resonating because one of the
things that makes me me
is i'm an anthropologist i read comments
at scale
on culture like i've read 150 comments
this morning
on the delta virus the delta variation
of the coronavirus
i didn't read the cdc or bbc
or reuters article about it i read
250 to 250 comments and observations
this morning
on twitter and instagram and a discord
on what they think what i i care about
what people's interpretations are you
got it yeah so that's what i do for a
living
so i do that with my own feedback so
something i realized that has really hit
that i'm gonna land right now and i hope
this helps somebody
when you realize that when you're lying
to yourself
and you're trying to hide something that
you if you're really good at it
you're gonna trick 98 of the losing
players on earth
the other insecure and i don't want to
call them losers but like
oth people that are not as emotionally
intelligent
one thing i've told a lot of friends
when they're faking the funk which means
when you're faking it you're anxious
yeah
right you're subconsciously always
waiting for the imposter syndrome to get
cloaked and what i've been trying to
tell people is like look
you're only tricking the other insecure
and unhappy you're
when you're tricking you're actually
losing with the two percent that you
want to win with
yeah yeah people the result of the truly
confident can see through that
correct and there's a lot of kids doing
damage to their
personal brand and by the way all the
personal brand is is the slang term for
reputation
you know you know a lot of people hate
that term and i always laugh i'm like
what about refutation
sorry i like that term i'm like good
don't call it personal grant anymore
this is just reputation at scale
um and so yeah so how do i think about
it i think about
speaking to its truth engaging with
people
suffocating excuses uh trying to
really really really i work on a lot of
my
people i most care about of please
please please
don't point fingers please point thumbs
if you can get into looking at yourself
when you feel somebody else is in
control
you're super vulnerable and when you're
in the index finger game
versus the thumb game you're extremely
vulnerable
because then you don't feel in control
when you don't feel in control
you feel helpless or manipulated and
it's a really sad state
when you give up your agency and you're
saying like the world is happening to me
instead of like i'm control and control
of my own experience
because there's there's uh nothing more
true to me than believing the world is
how you see it
because i have two very distinct sides
of my family
one is grounded in cynicism and one is
grounded in optimism
and that extremity and and by the way
extreme on both sides
i wouldn't call my optimism delusional
and i wouldn't call the cynicism blind
but my family's family tree
is pretty close to blind cynicism and
delusional optimism
and that's and that's how i think i
became me
right more than that yeah
um it just i have an extremely
optimistic
mother and an extremely cynical father
and their sides of the family
played out that way too and it just gave
me a huge perspective on life like
every situation i could literally see
the opposite like
i live life just and why i think i'm
balanced
by literally seeing the world through
both sides of the family's eyes
i could see every situation be like ah
my dad thinks that kid's gonna steal
my mom's gonna think that we can
reconcile him
ah yeah ah uh and so like everything i
look at
there the reason i think i've not gotten
into trouble
from uh over extend myself and lost is
i'm too practical i see
the wrong and everything
but but i choose the right in everything
i
see the wrong but i choose the right
was it always that way or like do you
train yourself to kind of embrace the
optimism side i was always naturally
optimistic but then when i started
spending time with my father
in my teenage years at the liquor store
when he's like the employees are going
to steal
the customer's going to steal it was
just that immigrant [ __ ]
you know yeah like and i used to blame
him and then i got older and
realized oh no i'm so wrong my dad was
born
in a country where that was true in a
communist country everybody stole
everything because the black market was
the country
and so i had to become more empathetic
but nonetheless um
yes it was always that way however
in in where you're going with the series
of your questions
i believe in osmosis
how do i teach people by talking about a
24 [ __ ] 7.
like what you put what you put in your
ears becomes your truth
for sure so so actually one one thing i
wanted to touch on that you talked about
just now was
you know you're doing a lot of things
that you don't like right like that like
working out every day you worked out
every day for six years
and you don't even like working out that
much right or or embracing that
feeling of uh you know kind of being
candid in your personal life or
you know behind the non-social media
life right like you know
uh when it sounds like maybe am i
one-to-one versus
you know cantor's easy when i'm talking
to the world because it's
i'm not talking to an individual human
right
be accountable stop taking like my
favorite one stop taking money from your
parents in your 20s and
watch your life get happier very easy
for me to put on instagram and tick tock
but i know people who are 27 that are
friends of mine
that are doing that and it's hard for me
to say that to them
right because there's that conflict
avoidance you know that that's not
natural
and so how do you motivate yourself like
you don't have to do anything you don't
want to anymore right like you're you're
successful
how do you motivate yourself to do those
things right like that was something
that
you know similarly i embraced much later
in life in my 30s
like i was like okay i'm going to do a
bunch of stuff that i like hate doing
that doesn't come natural to me how do
you how do you keep motivated to do
those things
and make those changes buy two things
by doing them around the things that are
important
to me that are logically important so
like there i always say if i brought a
thousand people into the room and asked
them the following question about me
hey do you think it's a good idea that
gary ate better
and worked out every day versus what
he's doing which is he's not
i'm gonna lose a thousand to zero
yeah and the market is always right as
much as i want to trick myself
that's that so like there is no doubt i
don't want to live with regret
justin regret scares me and even though
working out doesn't come natural
i know at 68 72 and 79
that it was two on my mind and i was too
woke to it
that if i didn't do anything about it
then i would really sit with regret
and i didn't want that i didn't want the
last 20 years of my life
having that pit in my stomach that the
[ __ ] was the matter with me of course
that excuse that i didn't have time i
was too but that's full of [ __ ]
you have enough time for everything so i
just pounded myself with that combo
until i finally figured out
my unlock and by the way on the record
for other people that have been
fortunate enough to be able to afford
this
mine was i'm more accountable to others
than i am to myself
so i hired a full-time trainer who's
just for me travels with me
is my guy that's his career and now i
don't want to let him down
i don't want to let mike vicanti down so
it made it easy
number two just
is again my who i am as a man
it was too obvious to me that if i asked
a thousand people and said you've
watched my whole life
was i right in this situation with these
57 things i can think of
900 of them would say no and that killed
me
because i love my emotional like
structure and so
what that was grounded in justin was is
it okay to say to justin who is my
direct report
everything's awesome you're gonna do it
try to build him up and then out of
nowhere
say you're fired by because i wasn't
able to give him critical feedback along
the way
and then blame him for not picking up on
the social cues
and the answer is those thousand people
would have said 900 would have said
you're wrong 100 would have given me
the excuse i had which is he was
delusional
he deserved right and once i realized
that
i said i can't do that i have to change
that oh [ __ ] i have a problem with
candor
it's hurting me in all facets of my life
except garyvee that's why everyone loves
him
[ __ ] i need to do this and i started
chipping away at it and it's still hard
it still does not come naturally as a
matter of fact i'm writing a new book
called 12 and a half
it's coming out in november it's called
12 and a half and it's
talks about i use the analogy in this
podcast so i like that you picked up on
it
it's basically the 12 and a half
ingredients for business success
and the reason it's 12 and a half is
kind candor
is one of them but i speak to that i'm
only halfway there and i only have 12
and a half of the 13 i need right now
yeah and i'm very self-reflective and i
tell everybody else look you might not
have it on ambition
or accountability or empathy or patience
or kindness that's okay we're all in our
journeys
but do not dismiss them because they are
true
i love that i i so so many of the things
that you
um are doing like the book uh you know
all the garyvee stuff it's like that's
content creation being out there kind of
creating this admiration
giving people advice that can change
their life like do you like that
like how does that sit with between that
and your business you know you like your
it seems like you're like i like the
business more
yeah as a matter of fact v friends my
new nft project
in some way subconsciously is
being built for me to be less garyvee
okay so what i mean by that is garyvee
is my vehicle to leave these good things
into the world that i know i have in my
soul
v friends empathy elephant patient panda
perspective pigeon is me now
transforming from being hulk hogan to
being vince mcmahon
so i believe i'm actually in the year or
within the six months
of something that will i will look back
on as a transformative moment in my
career
where i went from being hulk hogan the
star
of wrestling to being vince mcmahon the
architect
of the star of wrestling and still known
people know who vince mcmahon is
it's not like i'm going into the cage
but i'm going from
becoming from being mickey mouse to
becoming walt disney
people know walt disney but he's not
mickey mouse
i have a lot of passion for these
beautiful human traits like
when i tell you my my passion to make a
countable
ant which is the character i did for
accountability
yeah like big like kid robot like
smurfs like scooby doo like i want a
countable aunt
to be like [ __ ] hot like whether i'd
make a streetwear brand and do like vape
or whether i do a sunday morning cartoon
or whether i do
a cereal like a countable ant and
patient panda and empathy elephant
i'm gonna take gary vaynerchuk was the
architect of garyvee the delta between
garyvee and all the
mental strategy stuff versus gary
vaynerchuk the architect of it and then
the day-to-day operator of the 1500
vader x ecosystem it's actually not even
close
don't forget i was 30 before i made a
single piece of content it wasn't like i
had this i need to move to la and become
famous train i had this oh [ __ ] youtube
and twitter are gonna be the most
important [ __ ]
[ __ ] it i'm gonna like what do i do like
oh [ __ ] i'll just
jump in and take this spot for now and
now the next chapter of my evolution
will be
building the most significant
intellectual property
i i believe that v friends will have
incredible legacy as the first
intellectual property that was a billion
dollar
intellectual property built from nfts
the way that star wars was built from
film
the way that harry potter was built from
books the way that
angry birds was built from iphone games
and
what that will allow me to do is have
gary vee take a back seat
to the way i build up these far more
palpable
i mean me me i'm a high
energy east coast aggressive jersey
white male like like i'm not for
everyone
and right the fact that these characters
the 268 of them that i stood up
they will be for everyone once i break
them down into eight to 12 categories
and and i still can through them
help people unlock these emotional
traits that are absolutely justin
back to the beginning of this podcast
the foundations of happiness
[ __ ] this like how do people not
like the whole like money happiness
thing pisses me off
like how many people do we need that are
trillionaires that commit
suicide or how many people that you meet
that are well off that are deeply
troubled
like there is no correlation of wealth
and happiness how the [ __ ] are we
still confused this whole i'd rather cry
in a ferrari
is only said by people that don't
understand
nobody i get that comment a lot i want
to cry yeah i hate that comment like
[ __ ] that comment i'd much rather be
smiling in my [ __ ] leased honda
who the [ __ ] wants to cry because crying
in your ferrari
doesn't mean a tear once in a while it
means you are unhappy
you are insecure you're buying ferraris
to show people that you made it
you're trying to impress you people you
don't even like
and so how do how do people like so much
of society like catches us
in that trap right like it's almost like
everything instagram social media
like what you see on tv orient people
around if i make more if i
become more successful i'll um finally
be happy
and so how i don't know it's hard for
you to break out of that
i'll be honest with you i actually don't
think
well first of all you know this it
starts at home
you know you know like the household you
grew up in and what they valued
you know i love stereotypes because
stereotypes
are flawed because
making judgment on people like
everyone's is ridiculous
but stereotypes are also have nuanced
truths that's how they became
stereotypes
when i think about cultures that are
more happy like just they're
more free-spirited or happy you know you
see a family
environment where what they cared about
was
like family dinner on sundays or always
dancing and music and that like
it's just so obvious to me from afar you
know
the way you answer it and the way you
attack it
is in the meta right now we are two
gentlemen
who through hard work and serendipity
and
timing and a million trillion other
variables
have achieved business financial success
yet we feel compelled like a
fly going to the light or those bugs
outside in the summer
to talk about these things because we
just inherently know
that if you think a ferrari and a rolex
is going to make you happy you are
delusional
and like yeah and we've experienced it
from different
you know different angles and different
lenses you know
i'm coming from a place of somebody who
has never shown that
i've never you know i was never
attracted to it none of my friends were
that
i've never showed that in my content
it's not what i like
i also feel like i over demonized it
i've had a couple friends who really
like a good lambo or a watch
and they get not they get tiffed or they
disagree and i'm like you know you're
right i actually say i'm wrong i'm like
you actually like i've heard you talk
about that watch you spent four hours
talking about the breakdown of how it
works and the craftsmanship
but the reason i say it is because 97 of
people do not buy rolex
for its craftsmanship 90
85 whatever number you want to use and
and so i think it's important to teach
the kids
that and not even the kids the 60 year
olds because it's never too late to
change so
i just think it's the meta i think you
just try it's we choose what we're about
we choose what we talk about
i choose to talk about the fact that i
think kindness
and empathy is cool i also think that
accountability is required because so
much of our issues is that
we're in a culture now of trying to
convince others
instead of convincing ourselves
you know i don't think shame works i
don't think
no you know i don't think fear works
and i think multiple people do that to
each other from different angles and i'm
just trying to watch and observe and i'm
trying to put out
you know i don't you know i don't i have
a lot going on
why do i want to do this 45 minutes a i
want to keep seeing you win because i
see something from afar in the way
you're doing it
and when you're up to something and you
see somebody else have the potential to
like
expand on it we need as many allies into
mental happiness as possible
you know and so that but number two
it's because it's me living the answer
to your question
by allocating time time is my biggest
asset
and for me to allocate 45 minutes to
talk about it is me doing what you asked
which is i know i have a platform right
now
i especially have a very unique platform
i have incredible
right now now that every kid wants to be
an investor in a business man it's
[ __ ] crazy it must be crazy for you
too when we were growing up
how old are you it was not i'm 38 i'll
be turned 38 this year
amazing so you know this because you
lived it too it's insane like every 14
year old boy girl
i'm an investor i'm a entrepreneur i'm
going to be an influencer make my own
money like
this is like it's like the whole world
turned into
who i was at 14 and but i was the only
one at 14
when i was a kid now it's the standard
so now i know a lot of these kids you
know i lit now that the world's opening
up a little bit i'm getting outside
there's been a lot of growth even in the
last 18 months like
i walked by a gaggle of 15 year olds
that like
they started losing their mind and i'm
like oh my god this is getting crazy
so what do i do i i'm very thoughtful
about what i put on tick tock
and if i can get those kids if they
think i'm cool if i can get them
addicted to happiness
around good things
kindness like doing it for yourself
not for anybody else all that stuff then
you're leaving a little bit of a legacy
i love that which is absolutely which is
an absolutely my selfish place
my selfish place is the curiosity of how
big of a legacy can i build
and the only way i know how to build a
legacy is not how much money i make
nobody gives a [ __ ]
a small group may but they're not
sustainable anybody who cares about my
net worth
or how much money i made i'm not going
to penetrate them anyway
they're looking for short-term proxies
of a dorfy and like hits i got
i'm looking for people that looking to
run the marathon i'm not a sprinter i'm
not usain bolt
i'm not a spreadsheet i'm i'm a marathon
runner
i'm in kenya every day running 400
trillion miles
you know awesome that's amazing i love
that i love that mission
and i love that you're putting time into
that even though
yeah your you know business is your like
number one passion
you know it's kind of like the opposite
for me i realize that like i love
like i love creating content more than i
ever love running a business
like this is what i really love love to
do and so you know
it's funny to see that you know it it
shows
you know you know i've been like reflect
i've been reflecting too like why
your work recently has been so catching
my attention
that sentence made a lot of sense to me
yeah yeah i always just want i that and
it took me forever to realize that about
myself you know it took me like
36 years when i was like oh i should be
a business person and i love
you know my mom was an entrepreneur
everyone around me all my friends are
entrepreneurs that's what i thought i
was supposed to do and then
and i was just you know the content was
kind of incidental or whatever and now
i'm like oh actually i really love
creating content like i didn't love
managing people and running a business
like i you know i'd rather just be an
investor and content creator you know
and even say even saying just is that
hesitation but that's you know that's my
true joy and so
i'm happy you know it's funny as you
were talking i'm like my brain went to
this place where i'm like oh
i'll definitely prob you know that's
i'll definitely do that
at some point at some point for i can
see myself at 75 to 80 or
63 to 68 during the transition and go
back what a lot of people you know it's
funny
so many people think i'm a motivational
speaker and that's it
yeah that um that i'm a content creator
like like people like literally i read
the comp you know i read everything
they're like but what does garyvee do
and i laugh because
literally every day of my life that i've
been a professional
from may 1998 to june
2021 every single day
all 23 years of my entire professional
career
i have been the operating engine of a
business
as the last line of defense i have run a
business
every day for the last 23 years where i
am the singular energy
that is required to make payroll
and and and i love that
that being said could i really enjoy
not operating not having that
responsibility
doing the content thing and investing i
could
and i think a lot of people find their
way to that place
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon